-Our first guest tonight
is a legendary Academy Award
and Emmy-winning actress
and activist, whose new book
"What Can I Do?
My Path from Climate Despair
to Action," is on sale today
Please welcome back to the sho
Jane Fonda, everybody.
Jane, it is so lovely
to see you again.
-Good to see you, Seth.
I feel for you, man.
I can't even imagine what it
must be like playing in --
-Well, we have made
some progress,
because we spoke in April.
I was in an attic then.
And so,
while we're not fully back
we are taking steps
in the right direction.
-Well, you're great.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
I want to ask,
one of the things
you talk about in the book
is how your activism
has changed.
Obviously, this is something
that you have been,
for lack of a better word,
active in for a long time.
Can you speak to how
your activism in the '70s
versus your activism now
is different?
-Well, as I say
in the beginning of the book
in the acknowledgment,
you know, when I was young
I thought that activism was a --
was a sprint.
You know,
if I just go fast enough,
everything can be fixed
really quick.
And then, I got a little older
and I realized that activism
is more like a marathon,
and I slowed down
and learned to pace myself
But now that I'm seriously old
I realize
that it's really a relay.
It's a relay race.
You pass the baton,
and that's kind of what I di
this last fall and winter
with Fire Drill Fridays,
which is what
this book is about,
is what I did last year and what
I'm doing now virtually.
There were a lot of very,
very young people
who were complaining
there weren't enough old peopl
involved in the actions
to raise awareness of the
urgency of the climate crisis.
So I said, "Well,
I'm gonna answer the call.
An aging movie star.
I'll bop in there,
and I'm gonna
try to make a difference
and try to alert people
to what's happening."
But it was the young peopl
that really made the differenc
and woke me
and a lot of other people up
-It must be rewarding how people
have continued to engage
with Fire Drill Fridays.
Even it's become
a virtual event.
Has that been something that's
been exciting to you, as well?
-It's been unbelievable.
We've been doing it now
for six months.
And last Friday,
we had 750,000 people
following us
across all platforms.
July and August,
we had about 3.5 million people.
And tens of thousands have
signed up and are volunteering
to register voters
and get people to vote,
get out the vote,
Spanish-speaking volunteer
work with the Latinx community
And it's just amazing
what's happening.
-I know you obviously
would rather be doing it
in person than virtually.
I guess one of the up side
of doing it virtually
is you have not been arreste
for civil disobedience
in a while,
because you were really piling
up the arrests in recent months.
I guess, is it five times
that you were arrested
at Fire Drill Fridays?
Is that right?
-Yes, it is, yeah.
-And you were arrested, as well,
in the '70s,
but that was a whole --
a different story
compared to what's happene
in sort of recent days.
-Yes. Back in the '70s,
Richard Nixon was president,
and it was not
a voluntary arrest.
I flew from Canada
into Cleveland, Ohio,
and they arrested me
at the border
and took all my vitamin pill
and said they were drugs
and took all my books and papers
and address books.
And the guy --
the arresting officer told m
he was working from orders
from the White House.
So that was --
that was not so cool.
This time, you know,
it's different,
engaging in civil disobedience
It's not where you start
as an activist,
but for 40 years,
we've been petitioning
and protesting and marchin
and writing and lobbying,
and our voices
haven't been heard.
And, so, the next step
is civil disobedience.
And history has shown
that civil disobedience
is what changes history.
So that's what we did,
and it got a lot of attention.
And that's
what we were trying to do.
There are so many people
in this country
who know
there's a climate crisis
and know that
it's caused by humans,
and they want to do somethin
but they don't know what.
13 million of them said they
would do civil disobedience,
but nobody's asked.
So, we're asking.
-That's one of the many step
you lay out to people
in the form of solutions.
Because, obviously,
we are told often
what a crisis we're in
with the climate.
Was it important for you
in your book to both point out
what is going wrong and also
ways to correct it?
Sort of actionable items for -
if that's the best way
to describe it.
-Absolutely.
I mean, if I was asking,
before I went to D.C.,
"What can I do?", I knew tha
millions of other people
are wanting to know,
"What can I do?"
So, I wanted this book
to be an answer to them.
And each chapter, which focuse
on a different aspect
of the climate crisis --
oceans, forests, jobs,
migration, women,
et cetera --
each chapter ends with a section
called "What can I do?",
and it gives people
very tangible things
that they can do.
And at the top of the list
is always vote.
Make a plan, vote early, do it
-[ Laughs ]
That's a good message,
and I hope everybody hears it.
I also want to point out
you had a very nice reunio
with your co-stars
from the film "Book Club."
You did a virtual book clu
where you and Candice Bergen
and Mary Steenburgen
talked about the book.
Was that -- Was it enjoyable
to see familiar faces?
-Oh, I love them so much.
That's one of the great things
about being an actor.
Well, you meet new people
all the time.
-Yes.
-You get to know these peopl
that are so interesting and fun.
And, you know,
when you're older, though,
you have to make a real effort
to stay in touch.
So, last Friday was like
a reunion of Mary and Candy.
Diane was on her way to Arizon
to buy another adobe house
to change it up.
She's so good at that.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
That Diane and her adobe houses.
When will it stop?
[ Both laugh ]
-I know, I know.
But we are --
You know, there are over
5 million book clubs
in the United States.
Huge number of book clubs,
all women, mostly women.
And, so, what we are sayin
to them is, "If you give m
a good reason why I should
show up to your book club,
I'll -- I'll show up."
I mean, it's virtual.
But I'll send you my book,
and I'll sign it,
and then,
we'll have a discussion.
-Well, that's a lovely offer
And I should note, as well
that the proceeds of this book
100% of them,
are going to Green Peace.
-Correct.
-Thank you for
your generosity with that.
It's always such a pleasur
to see you, Jane.
Keep up the great work.
-Thanks a lot, Seth.
Good to see you.
Glad you're back on stage.
-Thank you so much.